[Music]
in same but different news submitted by
hound versus mountain you would get it
difficult when that was left unsure when
his infertile brother asked him to
donate his sperm to have a baby so lucky
I'm sure why isn't sure my little [ __ ]
that's why yeah that's crazy what what
if it was like can you [ __ ] my wife can
you do the natural way it's even better
different oh no cuz what if his wife was
hideous dude but you got to do it for
your oh maybe you doesn't wanna do his
wife's hideous he doesn't want to see
what the mix is am I the [ __ ]
subreddit yes you are so this is the
title it says MIT [ __ ] for not
wanting to donate sperm to my
parentheses sterile identical twin
brothers wife and in the fourth
obviously you guys aren't identical cuz
you got sperm and your brother don't got
sperm one difference alright so your
rights my brother who I have a very
strong bond and good relationship with
has been trying for years to get his
wife pregnant all to no avail
it's believed that he's sterile and this
saddens him and me very greatly a while
ago they accepted that he is unlikely to
ever have biological children and began
looking for a sperm donor but just
recently they posed a new unconventional
idea to me that I be the donor asking
your brother to donate sperm for you
might be an odd or even inappropriate
request in most circumstances but ours
is a unique one we are identical twins
we share 100% identical DNA and thus any
child born of my sperm would be related
to my brother every bit as much as his
own child from his own sperm would this
would be this would not be the case with
regular brothers where the baby would be
related as a nephew slash needs to him
and because of this the child wouldn't
find out about the donation from from
one of those home DNA test so many
people are taking now my brother and I
both would show up as he says the father
on any
DNA test because of our identical DNA so
what's the problem
yeah my brother's view my brother views
having an identical twin as a great
stroke of luck in this situation and an
opportunity to be able to have his own
children after all despite his
enthusiasm I'm not so sure about the
whole thing
I haven't officially declined I just
told him that I'll think about it I'm
married and just think and just think
the whole bet and just think the whole
thing seems a bit weird and off in my be
[ __ ] for not thinking about my
brother's meet Mead yes like if he knows
because he knows it's gonna be his kid
so that's why he doesn't want that it
seems like I just like ah like that's
your kid like it's not but it is like
that's Joris part so he might have an
attachment like it is his own he's like
all I wanna back yes now like you go to
a sperm bank that's like a kid he's
gonna have to see all the time like it's
his brother think it's his brother to
come in a cup okay a syringe and he's so
get up into the syringe thing and then
you inject it into the tip of your penis
and then you [ __ ] that sperm which is
also your sperm matching sperm into your
wife they do it all the time at clinics
yes I think if he's uncircumcised even
better yeah you I think just by him
knowing that it's just come that's what
[ __ ] with them this guy's a [ __ ] dude
it's brother now
what guy wouldn't want us to have his
common every single [ __ ] baby out
there I'm gonna have so many half
children spirit fear that's the best
thing though that's football players
style you have so many [ __ ] kids
y'all have to take care of yeah what
your genes go on yeah that's [ __ ]
dope like that that's rock star kingship
you can actually help your brother make
a kid that he can never have without you
though can somebody else nobody can't be
identical it won't be this bad that's
replicating yourself yeah he can
actually his mother could actually see
what the mix would look like
and that's not meant to because that's
one reason why I would don't want I
don't want to ever adopt in fact that's
why I think the doctor should be illegal
I don't want to see ya what my kid's
gonna look like between me and Nicky no
it's not just that I want to take over
the world with my genetics oh what a
gang has come the [ __ ] out of the
warranty
you said Genghis Khan Genghis Khan
Muskaan but Genghis Khan okay because a
lot of Asians have his DNA because he
[ __ ] so many girls that's crazy so I
mean like I don't have to [ __ ] a lot of
girls but if people maybe actually just
go to the sperm bank to make this happen
I'm sure a lot of people will want to
have it Val your sperm for sure yeah
yeah you know for the profile we just
have a link to JK news that's good
that's really good yeah
some comments from reddit this one says
nah it's your sperm you can absolutely
say no though I am curious why do you
want to say no do you think they'd be
bad parents does your partner have a
problem with it those are valid
questions you could say no but he's a
dick face those rubella I hate him yeah
another one says not selfish but maybe
idiotically insensitive uncaring I know
unaware the fact that you're so heavily
downplaying the importance of this
literally being his only shot at having
a child with his genetic material is
just sad dude it shows you aren't
grasping the full weight of this
decision
Slavko Kingsley you wanna go first of
all after identical why is he shooting
blanks
yeah how did that work maybe he got
involved in the tractor accident [ __ ]
mode and on/off or something maybe not
maybe he drank too much Mountain Dew I
just [ __ ] his dilemma I feel like it
makes sense it felt like you're trying
to hide it but oh if DNA tests come up
like he'll never know like what that's
like a pack this is like a secret yeah
it sounds like the the brother that's
sterile right yeah bringing it upon him
like a secret yeah just like that part
is weird if you're honest about it and
you talk to your kids here you are my
kid and your Dean have your DNA is your
your uncle's but the other half your DNA
is your mom's but you're my kid I think
I'd be cool so I don't see this guy is
an [ __ ] right like it is his [ __ ] so
it ultimately has to be his choice what
that it's that it's his brother or
whatever because like being assertive
his brother Jackson laughs secretly at
19 Thank You Bart that's a perfect point
I was trying to make myself you know
this if I'm the moderator at at am I an
[ __ ] I'd be like this isn't the wrong
subreddit this should be an MI a [ __ ]
because this guy I don't understand like
like it's he's not being an [ __ ] at
all he's just being really hesitant and
weird and like my [ __ ] is mine and it's
just weird to say it always come like
it's meaningless doesn't care about scum
he cares about have come obvious very
territorial I think what it is like like
what you were saying right he's gonna
feel this weird attachment to like
that's actually my can whatever and I
feel like surrogate moms kind of go
through the same thing so there's the
people like myself that I'm like man I
don't know if I could be a surrogate mom
because I'm gonna have this emotional
attachment even though it doesn't have
any of my genes it's like I created this
kid but dudes only have to jerk off in a
cup you don't have to carry the kid to
term Mull [ __ ] but it's not just that
because it's this guy's genetics to so
he's gonna feel like oh [ __ ] like I I
have some responsibility not only as an
uncle but now as a dad that's gonna be
awkward and their family but it's gonna
be the same interaction no matter what
so no it's like I'll thank God it's not
my [ __ ] I think it's like a mental
thing obviously right like it's just
like this little mental blocker where
he's like [ __ ] like like maybe he thinks
this brother's gonna be a terrible
[ __ ] pair and he's like I don't want
to bring this to this this is the best
of both worlds you get to have a kid
that looks like you and you don't have
to raise it you can just - yeah every
time I see this kid that's his kid steal
it bounce oh hell love it more so yeah I
get it I don't condone it let me ask you
a question yeah so let's say we're
trying to have kids yeah I don't have a
current here right now and I'm shooting
blanks like a mofo right but I have a
twin brother that has very juicy
Balzac's
really viral yeah they're like viscosity
right yeah oh yeah real thick really
bounce to it like it's a perfect white
comic
so the kind you want not beige not
though I'm Ruth we've already been not
Beijing not queer
so we've already been to a bunch of like
and I really want you want to have a kid
with me we went to a bunch of fertility
clinics sperm banks whatever and we were
gonna get sperm from someone else
anyways wouldn't you want this and
you're trying to have a kid with me
getting like a sperm from like some
redheaded Irish guy you can get it from
my twin brother so at least our kid have
some sort of resemblance to mature and
it's so sad right now
what did you wouldn't you rather do that
um yeah but I'm not I don't share what
he's saying though yeah like I'm trying
to put myself in if this willsez
knowledge about you selfish [ __ ]
no I wouldn't say you're selfish
[ __ ] I'd be like damn it's
unfortunate that you don't see it the
way you and I see it I wouldn't be like
he's [ __ ] selfish because it's it's
ultimately up to him weird Joe you're
very boring you're very boring so tell
me something would you donate your sperm
to a clinic for other people to use well
you don't know
[Music]
no unless I like one at the money like I
would just go let me really like
strapped for cash I've heard you can go
and do that yet I would never just like
if they had good porn I'd do it yeah
horn honks I hear ya
it's sticky man so you think I'm
identifying the difference cuz I would
do it I would do it good I'll be don't
you drink too much [ __ ] moms oh you
kidding me
those kids'll [ __ ] come out in 90
miles an hour do not kidding these songs
up the ass no they will not that's well
that's right are you ready teeth we're
gonna be born with the Mohawks and [ __ ]
don't be born on little dirt bikes of
[ __ ] yes so so but I think I would do
that so I think that's the difference
maybe is that you're very protective of
your coming weird impressions about your
comment on not especially you have a
twin brother right yeah like I would do
it for my brother I would that's what
I'm saying suicide especially do it for
my brother but maybe that's missing
children too I think he's pretty clear
like six years old they come out of
nowhere they're like I might change some
[ __ ] very responsibly
yeah I hope the mom plugin was she
became smarter because after having
you're coming right
yeah like kind of a 13 year old boy
would think about it yeah I get it
I hope my energy yeah change their
intelligence yeah like you know at that
time we made dumb choices right so I
hope that person grew and got a good
childhood and it wasn't a deadbeat that
took care of them but I'll be like
that's dope but at the same time I'm so
glad I had to go through those to take
care of up and out my genetics is it's
out there you donate your sperm pattern
brother yeah what would you donate to to
just society no help for you what you
keep that [ __ ] here so yeah I only don't
like the bathrooms and stuff just a pair
of socks that kind of stuff yep
why don't you want more kids if you
don't have to take care of them
mm-hmm why don't you want more kids
because I literally like five minutes
ago said we should stop making kids
because we're overpopulated no no no you
guys should stop
I want my clones to exist so it's a very
selfish spot okay he wants to take over
the world
it's just Ghengis Joe situation yeah
[Music]
[Music]